What we have just seen is called a
pshare predictor. It has a private history for
each branch. That is, each branch should have
its own history in the branch history table,
and it has shared counters so that different
histories and different branches, might map to the
same counters. This predictor is GOOD FOR things
like EVEN-ODD behavior like taken, non-taken, loops with
few iterations, for example, those 8-ITERATION LOOP that
we have seen and so on. So, pretty much
whenever the branch's own previous behavior is predicted
of its future behavior, pshare tends to do well.
Another type of similar predictor that we can
make Is called gshare, it has a global history
and shared counters. So a global history means
that there is only a single global history that
we use to predict all branches. So what we have is now the PC a single
history that we exert together and index into
the array of two bit counters. This history,
every branch decision, regardless of what the PC
of the branch is, gets shifted in here.
So what is gshare good for? It's good
for so-called correlated branches. That is, branches whose decision
is related to what the other branches in the
program were doing. Now I would think, when would that
happen? And it turns out that it happens in
programs quite often. Think about something like this. If my
shape is a square then do something. Then do
something that you do either way, regardless of what the
shape is. Then if sh, the shape is not square,
I have something else to do. This branch and this
branch are entirely correlated. If this one was taken,
this one will not be taken and the other
way around. So if this branch isn't the history,
when this one is being predicted then we can perfectly
predict this branch. Note that however, if we look
at this branch individually or this branch individually, the
history of this branch might be completely random because,
it really depends on our data, whether shapes or squares.
So if we randomly have shapes that are squares or not,
we cannot really predict much here. So, this branch might be mispredicted
often because we simply don't know at that point. But this branch
becomes perfectly predictable if it's using the history produced by this branch.